thanks gentlemen for joining us Steve
first wanted to address something so
couple publications that picked up a
tidbit in my story to both of you about
how you juggle your career at hgtc at
the ESPN I just wanted to give you a
chance to clarify how you do that
well sure Alex I think a lot of people
you leave the game I remember in one of
the things in the article is about Roger
Staubach sent me when you finished
playing run and it really isn't to run
away from the game it's really did not
dwell on it and have a plan and one of
the reasons what the reasons why we sat
down for their article was to talk about
mentorship and how I can get players
today to be thinking about their futures
how to get you know to make sure that
they're prepared with their education
other ways to conspire them so that
because no matter what I played 17 years
and still needed another career and I
built a expertise over the last almost
20 years in private equity but it
certainly I think I think a little
disservice in the article about my
passion and and expertise at ESPN and
for football I mean the truth is I spend
an ordinary out of time on in the fall
preparing for my job I the ESPN
gratefully put a camera into my office
so for an hour and a half on Wednesdays
I talked to PTI and go around the league
and all the issues in SportsCenter and
Thursday morning early morning we have
our production meeting for the Monday
show with our team of Trent and Charles
and and and Randy and and Suzy and then
Monday obviously on the field
pre-production meetings for and so
there's that for me and then on during
the game I mean if there's any
interaction with anybody away from
football it's at the you know we have a
two hour show before the game breaks in
there where we can say hi to people and
on the field and then during the game
the first quarter we spend watching the
game from the field get a feel for it
second and third quarters obviously the
bus are in a suite and then the fourth
quarter back on the field so I think
more than anything there's a little bit
of insecurity I think for players who
leave the game and and want to do
something else they wanted to create a
new profession a new expertise and I've
done that over again for over 20 years
but then my other expertise I don't want
to do disservice and my family to SPN
who you know Alex be honest with you
I've been with ESPN longer I was with
the 49ers and so there's so many rich
relationships there
and so you know and I feel like I've
been doing for 15 years in fact I think
it's probably for me maybe my best year
this year and including the post game of
Super Bowl so I think more than anything
an article certainly don't misconstrue
my passion and and focus for for doing a
great job I feel like there's not in
conflict the two jobs and at all and and
I'm really lucky to have them both so I
think I think anyone who's listened to
you knows certainly you know how
excellent you are at football
commentating and and I will say that the
point of bringing that out in the story
is to simply alert people to the fact
that you do have two things going on at
once which I think a lot of people don't
realize and that's sort of getting into
your hgg see so it's a good segue
tell us how you learned about the
private equity industry and you
mentioned you've been doing this
actually longer and you've been playing
professional football yeah so luckily I
made good friends with Warren Hellman
and Larry Smith seen he was on a board a
PowerBar back when I was playing and I
got introduced to the business world and
then rich Lawson on my left here was the
CEO of a business that I started while I
was finishing playing and so that's how
we got connected and then Bob Gay a good
friend of mine who was with Bain Capital
for years when I was an investor in
those funds gave me an opportunity to
transition you know from football into
private equity and Direct Investing in
2001 with Sorenson capital rich and I
were founding member members there and
so that's how I kind of made my
transition a lot of others from Silicon
Valley relationships that I'd built
while we were playing Harris Barton
Brent Jones ronnie Lott a lot of us were
sit around the locker room and we're
thinking about how can we get involved
this explosion of Silicon Valley around
our Santa Clara practice facility how
can we you know take advantage and learn
and we got great relationships in the
venture capital world and that's kind of
how there's a natural it seems odd when
people meet me and say how are the
worlds you get started in private equity
but there was a natural way being in
Santa Clara night thinking around
Silicon Valley during the you know the
late 90s rich tell us a little bit about
hgg C's strategy because you guys have
an investing philosophy that is pretty
unusual these days in private equity
well it is Alexson it only in this
global economy right in that 17 short
years that Steve had mentioned we've
been able to grow hgtc to a little over
four billion dollars of capital under
management we have over 46,000 employees
involved
our portfolio companies and we continue
to do what we call middle market private
equity control deals there's a
tremendous opportunity today to go back
to basics and what private equity used
to be in the 90s in terms of the average
size and we've we've had a great run
it's been a been a tremendous
opportunity and it's been a great time
to be able to work with Steve along the
way over nearly two decades Alex you
read more about HDC in this week's
business week as I mentioned Steve have
you ever miss if I didn't ask you a
football question or two you did publish
a book recently your autobiography my
life behind the spiral and the first
quote on the back of this book is from
Tom Brady so I have to ask you is Tom
Grady the greatest quarterback of all
time now sure feels like it with five
Super Bowls I mean it's amazing I was
sitting on the field and as I mentioned
I did post game of the Super Bowl and
and we were watching it that last couple
of drives from the side of the from the
field and you think yourself the
enormity of the moment that come back
the greatest comeback in the history of
the Super Bowl and then also what tom
has done over and over again and in the
postgame I referred to him as
relentlessly excellent and and that
really came through as he finished the
game it almost felt inevitable when he
got those opportunities towards the end
of the game and I don't know that
anyone's been able to do that over five
Super Bowls and so obviously with Joe
Montana with all the great players I'm
not great at picking the greatest of all
time because I think each generation
builds on the next is informed by the
previous and so for me who was the
greatest of their generation and Tom
Brady certainly is